to present our next award a native
daughter of California who shines in
such films as lovers and other strangers
and the Godfather Diane Keaton and with
her a gentleman whose evidence as a
director is indisputable three Academy
Awards the Thalberg award and the
respect and loving affection of the
millions of love such films as his best
years of our lives watering Heights mrs.
Miniver Roman holiday
etc etc Santa mr. William Wyler
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. Weiler you're more used to getting
Oscars than giving them out it's more
fun all right now those nominated for
best achievement in directing are
Frederico Fellini for a mccord stand a
cubed the belly engine Sidney Lumet for
Dog Day Afternoon
[Applause]
[Music]
Robert Altman for national
[Music]
Milosh Foreman for One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest
[Music]
[Applause]
the winner is
Miller's for me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
first I thank the Academy for the
company of the nominees they did put me
in I'm very proud of that when I I want
to think what possible reasons I'm here
now I can find to the first is that this
year the Academy members recognize the
fed that last year I spent more time in
a mental institution than the others and
the second might be that well but
America still is big beautiful
hospitable and open country I think you
saw Michael Jack Louise can easy and
especially I want to thank all those I
host names I don't have time to mention
now thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]